o convite lá vai se transformar numa
gripe e a gente vai precisar tomar
vacina todos os anos olha a gente não
tem como responder essa pergunta
definitivamente ainda porque ainda não
se tem a informação definitiva de quanto
tempo dura a imunidade contra ela nem a
imunidade natural através das pessoas
infectaram e também nem a imunidade
intercorrente prazo vacinas que vão ser
aplicado então partindo do pressuposto
que a imunidade dure meses teve sim
teremos que tomar vacina contra convite
todos os anos e partimos do pressuposto
que a imunidade dura mais durar anos
talvez não tenhamos que tomar vacina
todos os anos ou seja ainda é cedo para
saber mas o que muito provavelmente se
confirme é que tenhamos que todos
o tema só estará resolvido quando
tivermos a você e falando na vacina né e
nessa questão da reflexão tá lá e nessa
imunização de rebanho isso não é real né
esse conceito da imunidade de rebanho
ele é um conceito que existe um conceito
da epidemiologia basicamente quanto tá
lidando com uma doença que não é nada
grave olha tu pode ir a deixar que a com
que compensa a imunidade de rebanho ou
seja dessas pessoas infectadas a maioria
quase ninguém vai ter nenhum problema e
aí tu tu acaba com o risco de contagem
porque todo mundo do código essa tenta
aí tenta chegar as pessoas eu tenho
decorre o problema é que coronavírus
matam por cento das pessoas que ele
infecta então que a gente vir a
imunidade de rebanho como política de
saúde a gente estaria que as teria que
aceitar que ele vai matar quase 1 milhão
de brasileiros e aí óbvio que nem
tu acha isso magoado então a imunidade
lembram com cê existe que pode ser
adequado mas não no caso do coronavírus
não sei o exemplo que eu mais gosto de
dar eu exemplo da espanha na espanha os
números estão diminuindo dia a dia já
faz muito tempo e o ultimate 5 porcento
da população tenha sido infectado ou
seja é possível que os números baixem
mesmo um percentual bem baixo da
população infectada essa que deve ser a
prioridade no brasil também mas se para
a gente baixar esses números o que que a
gente tem que fazer porque eu fui
comprando no jornal isso tem muda
diariamente né mas tem muitos estados
que estão com os números elevados não é
um dia eram a maioria outro dia nem
tanto daqui a pouco volta mas se a gente
levar em consideração que muitas pessoas
acabam morando numa cidade indo
trabalhar em outra ou mês
o estado não seria um presente um lock
down todos os em todo o país só isso é
uma coisa fora de questão a gente tem
que aprender com os lugares que deu
certo por exemplo a europa em geral não
foi um exemplo bom combate ao
coronavírus duas neste quisito eles
foram bem quando o coronavírus estava
bombando lá ele fecha tudo e aí eles
fechando tudo o vírus parou de circular
e como os números começaram a sair as
duas estratégias mais efetivas que nós
temos notícia no mundo até agora é
testagem e massa castramento de contato
isso foi feito em alguns lugares da ásia
em poucos lugares da europa mas eu não
fez segundo quando a doença tá bombando
nokdal brasil também não fez por isso
que os nossos números não estão viajando
e aqui foi isso porque o velho tem muita
pressão de muitos lados tem muita
desinformação mas
e se parece que é tão difícil da de
alguns setores entender que é necessário
parar para que as coisas melhorem para
todo mundo se colocou no brasil uma como
tudo aliás que acontece no país
atualmente infelizmente se colocou uma
que polarizou diz o pessoal que pediu os
defensores da economia de fênix tudo
fique aberto e que abre abre abre e o
defensores da saúde de defendem que tudo
fica fechado fechado fechado só que na
prática essa dicotomia não é verdadeira
hoje no rio grande do sul não tem
nenhuma dúvida que a gente fizer unlock
dar um rigoroso no estado hoje está
fronteira apertar as porcas capital a
gente retoma inclusive a atividade
econômica mais rápido
e o problema é que a gente fica nesse
look da 16 boco nesse lançamento
meia-boca e aí tanto a economia quanto à
saúde pública pagam mais caro então
vamos lá segundo ponto essa politização
absurda que o país enfrenta polarização
então é óbvio que um país que no começo
da epidemia o presidente dizia que era
uma gripezinha
as outras pessoas diziam que era que ia
matar um milhão de pessoas etc e tal
ficou nessa nessa discussão e aí ficou
com essas cortinas de fumaça e vezes um
frango tá o assunto por exemplo política
de testagem em março é algo que a gente
sabe desde uma hora desculpa e o brasil
não fez nenhum momento
é só que é tão meia-boca que tu disse de
distanciamento e não me focando nos
problemas reais que estamos trazendo tu
consegue prever o que vai acontecer com
a gente nos próximos meses vamos olhar
para os casos que a gente tem que
comprar nossa casa da europa são os
lugares que fizeram lock down e groso
a segunda onda porcos a itália não tá
tendo segunda onda forte na frança não
está tendo segunda onda na espanha e
certo por um surto e barcelona a própria
china agora surgiu uma segunda onda uma
semana atrás mas já controlar a verdade
aqui os lugares que fizeram lock down
rigoroso conseguiram abrir e tá dando
certo então
a tua no brasil alguns lugares já estão
realmente de manaus um bom evento manaus
um lugar onde está diminuindo
sensivelmente o
e no brasil continuar fazendo essa
política de distanciamento mãe a boca o
que vai acontecer que os números só vão
começar a cair quando chegar no estágio
que nem aquele de manaus tá ok tudo
lotado cemitério bombando hospitais
bombando claro vai chegar amanhã porque
tu vai diminuir que nem aconteceu em
manaus porque a epidemia não consegue
durar tanto semanas assim porque a
epidemia não consegue
é só seguir contaminado por tempo
indeterminado agora existiria maneiras
mais fáceis mais seguras e com menos
custos e com menos vidas tendo perdido e
resolveu o problema infelizmente não foi
a nossa alça escolho
bom então realmente a gente tem que
fazer alguma coisa né porque o preço é
muito alto né não eu gosto de falar
a melhor desculpa eu vou eu vou fazer
uma analogia que eu acho que é louca vai
exatamente correta tá matematicamente é
matematicamente a terra mas
epidemiologicamente não é mas é uma
forma das pessoas se darem conta do que
eu tô falando a gente hoje tem o que nós
temos hoje quase 80 mil mortes 79.000 do
brasil a eu não tenho 80 mil mortes no
brasil pela nossa pesquisa da última
fase tinha quatro porcento quais da
população infectada vamos dizer que
agora aumentou para seis setembro
bom então se com seis por cento da
população infectada tem 80 mil more que
a gente formou mimir alma a imunidade de
rebanho de sessenta por cento a gente
vai ter 800 mil
o que a gente quer fazer uma unidade
leblon dessa doença não precisa chegar
em outro aí e sessenta por cento se
chegar em 40 porcento já começa a baixar
tá então então nós vamos ter 400 a
questão é nós estamos por nós achamos
isso razoável não então não dá para
pensar que a imunidade de um banho vai
nos resolver o problema a única forma de
resolver nosso problema o distanciamento
social rigoroso e coloque tal e aí
infelizmente eu não vejo o clima né
porque as pessoas não entendem que o
nosso down é tão necessário infelizmente
até parece até tô feliz porque ouvi
falar que porto alegre tá pensando em
fazer o nosso dar um rigoroso sério
tomara porque vai ser um exemplo talvez
depois seja seguido por outros lugares
do país outra coisa assim que eu vejo
muita gente comentando
em toda semana alguém diz que os
próximos 15 dias vão ser mais é não é
como que isso funciona para as pessoas
entenderem realmente o que que significa
né o primeiro dizer que numa pandemia
tudo e é momento é importante a nossa
não a poderia então as próximas duas
semanas são importantes depois as outras
duas também porque o pessoal fica
tentando botar essa esse time sair a
ideia é fazer com que as pessoas se
preocupam com seriedade sobre o mas
sinceramente uma pandemia todos os
momentos tão importante o que que
aconteceu aqui no rio grande do sul
vamos vamos trazer para nossa casa aqui
lá em março abril tava muito no começo
nosso estudo mostrando sempre que a
pandemia tava muito no começo
a gente fazia pesquisa dava dois
infectados em 4 mil e poucas pessoas
depois dava 6 horas a gente vê que tá dá
para falar a verdade comparado conversa
do brasil
e os números estavam bem a gente dizia
olha a gente não pode cair no erro
a entender bom agora então a gente tem
que abrir tudo e a gente caiu desse ano
então se o número só aumentam de novo é
porque a gente que abriu nessa hora
tivéssemos conseguido segurar de verdade
talvez hoje tivesse já com a curva na
descendente mas não conseguimos não
houve essa capacidade do estado então é
isso não tem fórmula mágica nesse troço
coronavírus se a gente olhar o que os
outros países fizeram só tem duas coisas
que deram certo até agora
o estágio e mata em busca de contato e
lançamento social rigoroso coloque down
na pior hora da poderia não tem nada que
alguém fez que foi milagroso no começo
eu sei que vai te lembrar o pessoal
falava nada nos países onde a bcg
universal não vai ter nos países onde é
verão e fala de tudo isso é de clima
você falava de um bonde de máscara não a
república tcheca não comer não todo
mundo vai sair vai usar máscara tá bom a
suécia disse que tinha descoberto a
solução do mundo ela mandar todo mundo
para rua e fazer isolamento dedicar todo
mundo faz isso então todo mundo voltou
atrás que foi horrível a única coisa que
realmente deu certo foi logo que não e
políticas paga e agora que tem alguns
números que estão falando a palavra
agora é platô né e aí eu vejo algumas
pessoas comentando como se isso fosse
uma coisa boa isso
que coisa boa né porque se os números
tão altos estão ruins e estão no trator
eles são né
e não é porque tava estacionado que o
carbona que que a gente tá mais
preocupado assim com a coisa do platô a
coisa que a gente tá mais preocupado
completo é que a nossa curva e vamos lá
hoje em dia todo mundo sabe essa coisa
da curva a
bom e então quando eu falar pessoas vão
entender o grande problema do nosso
platô e da nossa curva essa é a nossa
curva ela tá mais gorda do que a dos
outros lugares então vamos lá a
e todo mundo tá acostumado com aquele
desenho tá e a nossa curva tá mais gorda
porque porque esse nosso platô tá
demorando mais tempo então o porquê
claro que agora é hora de começar as
subiu subiu subiu chegou aqui o normal
seria fazer assim tá só tô na rua ele
fica fazendo assim vai demorar mais eu
descer então o platô e final problema
muito pior quando está subindo ainda não
tá sentindo mais felizmente do país como
um todo agora esse platô por tempo muito
longo é única e exclusivamente
decorrente da falta de calçamento fosse
alto fizesse tratamento rigoroso quando
estamos nesse pastor a curva ia cair que
nem caiu na frança na alemanha na até no
reino unido já caiu então é isso o platô
não é ruim por si só ele só tá demorando
mais o precisar falar um pouco sobre o
estudo também porque que ele foi feito
ico quais são
e os resultados e ainda tem mais uma
etapa se eu não me engano né dele tem
mais rápido porque o estudo foi feito é
analogia do iceberg é mais fácil para as
pessoas compreenderem a gente tinha uma
doença chegando no brasil e a gente pelo
que via na europa no resto do mundo tem
um conjunto de casos oficiais que era os
casos aparentes seria analogia do art 13
a ponta visível do espelho mas esses
casos que apresentavam uma fatia pequena
do total de casos na população então o
estudo veio para gente olhar o áspero
como um todo seja para compreender a
real dimensão da doença é isso aí
e a pesquisa aqui no rio grande do sul é
localizada em 9 cidades estão as maiores
cidades de cada uma das mesorregiões do
estado cada fase a gente entrevista e
presta quatro mil e quinhentas pessoas
nós já fizemos cinco fases dessa
pesquisa essa semana faremos a sexta
fase dessa pesquisa e já temos mais duas
planejadas sétimo e oitavo então essa é
um ter a pesquisa do rio grande
e o intervalo entre as pazes agora é de
quatro semanas exceto se aumentar muito
a prevalência ea prevalência de acima de
um por cento da população infectada
diminui o intervalo para de três em três
semana e a prevalência de acima de cinco
porcento diminui o intervalo para de
duas em duas semanas a gente vai fazer
aí mais uma coleta de dados agora esse
fim de semana e vamos relatando as
novidades depois o brasil ministério da
saúde nos encomendou que a gente
expandir-se sua pesquisa para o país
inteiro a gente fez três fases da
pesquisa mesmos mosko duas semanas de
intervalo entre elas essas três fases da
pesquisa foram no meio de maio começo de
junho final de junho as três fases foram
concluídos os resultados foram
amplamente divulgados e agora não há
sinalização do ministério da saúde já
passaram aí
há quase 20 dias desde a divulgação e da
má sinalização que a gente continue
fazendo a pesquisa então a principais
tudo nacional encerrou por enquanto eu
estudo gaúcho a gente tem mais três
fases por fazer a gente ainda está
buscando parceiros para seguir o estudo
nacional mas essas são as informações e
resumo os resultados do estudo gaúcho
mostro e na última fase o percentual de
infectados é de meio por cento ou seja
de cada 200 gaúcho e gaúcho tinha um
infectado claro que isso é quase um mês
atrás então agora que nós vamos fazer a
realidade atual é fim de semana a gente
também encontrou confirmamos a tal da
teoria do astra gol seja o número de
pessoas infectadas é muito maior do que
aparece nas estatísticas oficiais e são
os principais resultados eu ainda só vou
acabar mais o resultado antes da gente
esperar uma
é muito no começo a pandemia é que essa
doença maioria das pessoas não tinha
sintomas e não é verdade o nosso estudo
nacional mostra que quase 90 anos tem
sido assunto sejam sintomas leves só
para ter uma ideia aqui um sintomas que
é super clássico que é o sintoma de
perda de olfato e paladar
e sessenta por cento das pessoas que têm
coronavírus relax sintoma então assim
essa ideia de que não dá porque as
pessoas vão transmitir transmitem
silenciosamente o vírus para estar
equivocado ela tem sintomas são sintomas
leves mas as pessoas têm sintomas de
forma que seria possível sim identificar
aquelas pessoas em risco testar e aprova
os contatos que é o que a coreia fez
infelizmente o brasil nunca não sabe
sapat
é porque a gente falar muito nos
assintomático
oi léo e ficou vídeo de moto não é bem
assim
bom e aonde a gente pode ver se
resultado por exemplo que sintomas são
ele a gente tem isso publicado no a
gente botou a clara a gente está
escrevendo um artigo escrevendo aqui
para publicação mas a gente já tem esses
resultados mais eles estão divulgados
tanto no release que a gente mandou para
mídia quanto não pré pre-print que tá no
é dor tarde ele tão servidor mas eu
posso te mandar o
o o o arquivo é o próprio diz para te
dar uma olhada nos resultados ele pede
aí depois eu te mando ele pode
compartilhar que bom então tá bom tempo
para encerrar tem alguma coisa que tu
gostaria de dizer que a gente não te
perguntou toque tentar dar um recado
porque agora uma coisa que está muito na
moda agora é o pessoal ficar indignado
porque a gente defende lá que da alma e
aí eles ficam bravos e dizem lá mas é
fácil defender lapidar um para quem tem
salário todos os meses certo e tal você
dizer que na prática não é bem isso
quando a gente fala em loki dar a gente
pensa inclusive na economia se
fizéssemos eu não tenho dúvida nenhuma
dizer isso até agora fizemos um nokdal
de duas semanas rigoroso no rio grande
do sul vai ser melhor inclusive para
economia problema que as pessoas não
acreditam nisso as pessoas estão se
enganando com essa política de que vai
reabrir dos pouquinho ninguém tá indo
comprar vamos falar a verdade então o
comércio pelo
a duda tá perguntando dinheiro ao invés
da gente fazer o que os outros lugares
fizeram é um lock down rigoroso para
reaquecer a economia mais rápido quando
voltar então é dizer que essa dicotomia
entre economia e saúde é uma dicotomia
completamente equivocado e as pessoas
que dizem essas coisas estão na minha
percepção não entendendo o que que é a
melhor solução inclusive para clube e